hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts emerging trends
cell-free DNA based screening for common
and employees presented by Glenn Palo
Mackey he is a professor of the
department of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine women and infants hospital
albert medical school at Brown
University
I am Marjorie Torres elaborate and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web summon are presented by
lab week's lab Ruth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want like anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions it's real time
for at the end of the presentation maybe
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of the
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
that offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Glenn Palomar I will now turn the
presentation over to him hello and
welcome I'm Paulo Mackey I'm giving you
a presentation today about cell free DNA
screening for common autosomal trisomies
and and other disorders as well as
emerging trends surrounding that so you
get an idea of what might be coming in
in the near future I the disclosures are
there essentially everything goes
through my Hospital I don't have any
personal contracts with anyone and our
outline the main part of the talk the
first four bullets have to do
with really cell-free DNA first five
maybe and then the last four have to do
with kind of competing models or
methodologies that somehow might merge
together with cell-free DNA testing in
the near or longer-term future so let's
just start off with kind of an
introduction to this and even this
background going a little bit further
back where were we in 2000 of scene and
the best test screening test that was
available back in 2010 was a combination
of both first trimester and combined
test like Norva nuchal translucency pap
a and and free beta added to the
quadruple test in the second trimester
which is FPU III HCG and inhibin which
creates what's called the integrated or
sequential test and at roughly a 1 and
100 cutoff you can see the little
vertical line here these are the
overlapping distributions here the
normal or euploid pregnancies with with
one in 10,000 ring you know very low
risks and here are the doubters the Down
syndrome distribution with very high
risks the cutoff is about one in a
hundred and you can see that only this
little portion of the euploid pregnancy
would be screened positive while the
vast majority of the Down syndrome is
screened positive roughly a 90%
detection rate for a 2 percent false
positive rate and that's really a pretty
good prenatal screening test it's about
a forty five fold increase in risk on
the woman's age if she's pretty positive
so that's where we were it's a pretty
good test but it's it you know could
always be improved
whoops and it was 1997 Dennis lo and
colleagues at Chinese University of Hong
Kong
Atlanta where plasma from pregnant women
and simply had a Y krob and the manatees
they all showed the Y probe mark and the
four subsequent samples were for females
they didn't and
you may be the link that if there's Y
material circulating in a pregnant
female than the Fiat must be male and of
course they'll be delivered a male and
the other four delivered a female so
this showed that there was circulating
fetal placental DNA in the maternal
circulation but there was not much you
could do with this except perhaps
determine the the fetal sex until there
was more work done in next-generation
sequencing so let's just look at some of
the characteristics of this cell-free
DNA so there's a free fetal cell freak
maternal DNA that's circulated in the
plasma now we always call it fetal DNA
but we know now it's placental in origin
so if you think of cell free DNA as a as
a test it's more like a CV app which
will send the materials then like an
amnio which is taking feel material so
the maternal DNA comes mainly from the
the circulatory system the cell free and
maternal DNA are all quite chopped up
averaging something perhaps 150 to 200
base pairs but as small as 50 and as as
big as perhaps three four hundred and
they represent the entire genome I'll
show you what that means in a minute but
what's really interesting is the last
bullet you may know that fetal cells are
one in a million one in ten million
circulating cells but fetal DNA is about
10% of the total circulating cell-free
DNA so if you were to select ten
fragments of DNA from the circulation
it's likely that one of them will be
fetal placental in origin the other nine
will be maternal and we'll see that this
ratio of fetal to maternal or the fetal
fraction turns out to be an important
variable in this testing so there's some
information about cell free DNA now this
is the human genome ordered by
chromosome you know one is the largest
and this gives it an megabases or the
percentage of the genome so the you know
the first chromosome is about 8%
and the 21st chromosome trying to stick
this number in your head for a little
while it's going to come back one about
one and a half percent relatively small
amount so only one or two fragments per
hundred are going to be coming from the
21st chromosome so these fragments the
in circulation represent all of these
chromosomes in roughly they not actually
roughly but almost exactly the
proportion that it should be so now I'm
just going to go through what's called
shotgun counting sequencing - to test
for common trisomies so these are this
is a representation of the fragments in
the maternal circulation the red
represent the fetal the black the
maternal this is a blood I guess this is
the needle this is a nice set of
schematics that rose at you again from
Chinese University of Hong Kong put
together so this is going to sample this
these fragments and sequence them and
they're gonna sequence in 36 base pairs
and there's nothing magic about 36 base
pairs the point of of sequencing some
part of that fragment again that
fragment might be a hundred and fifty
base pairs what we're interested is what
ransom did it come from in this case the
36 base pairs mapped uniquely the
chromosome seven so if you think about
it if you're going to sequence a million
fragments it means that a million times
you're going to have to do an alignment
with a human genome and try and figure
out is it on chromosome 1 2 3 4 oh I
found that on chromosome 5 I can stop no
you can't because that might be
duplicated on chromosome 11 so every
single sequence has to be checked
against the entire genome and you can
see that's a lot of bio why didn't
that's less why sequenced 15 it would be
faster wouldn't it well if you sequenced
only 15 there would be a lot of matches
and then they wouldn't be unique and you
say well then want to use sequence 60
and the answer is well then you're using
up a
of additional sequencing and expense and
it really doesn't get much better so
could you do 30 for sure could you do 41
sure there's no magic 236 but the point
of the sequence is to try and uniquely
describe that fragment to a chromosome
then the next step is is simply a beam
counting so in this case you know you do
a sequence and you can see that there
are six of them that go to chromosome
one and so on and so on and so on and if
you're you're really good at it you'll
see that there are 51 dots and you go to
the 21st chromosome and there's only
there's only one fragment that map to
the 21st chromosome in my first 51
fragments well that's one out of 51
which is 2% and do you remember what we
thought it ought to be in the genome it
ought to be one and a half percent so by
counting only 51 we've actually gotten
pretty close to the right answer but you
can see if we if we want to get a really
good estimate we got to count a whole
lot more than 51 you have to count not
thousands or tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands but millions of
fragments all right so let's say that
you have sequenced and aligned millions
of fragments how do you test somebody
then so you you figure out how many
fragments map to chromosome 21 for the
for the woman the patient whatever you
want to call and compare that to the
mean I said it's about one one and a
half percent it isn't exactly one and a
half but one and a half will work and
then express it as a z-score well that
sounds like math so we better go through
this a little bit so let's say that I
found I have already sequenced a number
of normal euploid pregnancies more than
just six but I just going to display six
let's say I did a hundred or so and I
calculated the average is one point five
and I calculated the standard deviation
and this standard deviation passed one
of the early is next-gen sequencing
going to be precise enough to do this
sort of testing do you think
so if this is very tight this might work
and let's say then I get a one point
five nine percent that's a little bit
above one point five is it is that high
enough to say it might be trisomy there
might be some extra material from the
fetus that has three 21 chromosomes and
the answer is you go to the z-score
calculation which is simply what's the
patient's value one point five nine -
what I expect to get one point five that
distance expressed as standard deviation
units so it's point O nine divided by
0.02 is four point five and if you
remember back from your statistics
anything much more than two or three SDS
is highly unlikely to have occurred by
chance
so this finding says this looks like
there's way too many 21 chromosome
fragments than I would expect and you
can say that's consistent with the fetal
fetus being affected with Down's
syndrome and this is from our large
external validation that started
clinical testing back in late 2011 here
is those 21 chromosome 21 z-scores that
I just showed you how to generate if you
drew a line at plus 3 and minus 3 you
would expect your euploid pregnancies
the blue dots to fall somewhere between
plus or minus 3 standard deviations
pretty unlikely to be above but if you
look real carefully there's one there's
two there's 3 so 3 out of about 1500
would be falsely positive so this cutoff
the red dots are the downs and you can
see that there are 1 2 3
actually there's there's 4 below but
only 3 of them are actually falsely
negative you also if we look at the x
axis now what's the X action it's the
fetal fracture remember we said that the
average is about 10% well there's the
10% fetal fraction and you see as the
fetal fraction goes up in other words as
more and more of the material that
you're
testing comes from the fetus it becomes
easier and easier to separate the normal
from the Down syndrome and if we go down
to the other end you see all of the
errors occurred at fetal fractions that
were you know four or five six percent
and say well wait a minute I'll see
anything below four well all the samples
below four were called test failures
because they weren't confident that they
had sufficient information to make a
call so with very low fetal fractions
one you might have failures too that's
where you might have false negative
results now what I have to tell you is
this was all done in testing was 2,000
actually it's more than six years old
the testing was done in 2010 so it's
actually about eight years old now so
there's this is what testing was like
back in 2010 before it was even
clinically available so things should
have gotten a bit better and I think
they have now if we kind of compare the
graphic here with the graphic for
integrated testing so this is cell free
DNA and the maternal plasma very high
performance we found just over 98% I
think nowadays it's more like 99% we had
about 0.2 point three percent positive
now it's down around point one point two
percent positive and you look at the
distribution of euploid it is very tight
notice it's not centered at one point
five I lied it's one point three seven
to something or other but that's too
hard to remember so you can draw a
cut-off at roughly three SDS that's what
this corresponds you and if we were to
zoom in here you can kind of see yeah
okay there might be a few false
negatives there may be a few false
positives but it's almost diagnostic and
you say well is this test diagnostic and
the answer is we have a lot worse tests
that are called diagnostic the only
reason this is not diagnostic is because
we have a better test than this and
that's amnio CVS karyotype microarray we
do have a a kind of true diagnostic test
so this
to still be considered a really really
good screening test but not a diagnostic
test screen positive results should be
followed up with the offer of
amniocentesis and karyotyping or CBS and
microwave something like that
so what I just showed you was called the
shotgun counting you can see why there
are other methods I'm not gonna go into
detail but there's there's some methods
that say well you know why are you
sequencing chromosome 1 2 & 3 I mean
we're only interested in 21 18 13 and
maybe X&Y so I'm gonna create a method
where I only pull out fragments from
what I'm interested in I have to do a
whole lot less sequencing but then I
still count the same way as I did before
so you instead of shotgun sequencing
it's targeted sequencing that should be
a little less expensive but you'll see
you're limited as to what you can find
if you wanted to find trisomy 16 you
can't do it here unless you add some
targets for chromosome 16 here you can
find chromosome 16 if you wanted to do
by just doing some extra you know
mathematics the data are there and then
there's a completely different method
that uses snip pattern Matthew so it
selects snips spread across two
chromosomes 21 18 13 X&Y or whatever
else you want and then rather than
counting it's actually looking at
patterns and it gets a bit complex but
it's a it's more pattern matching than
it is counting you you I think I'll just
leave it there but there are other
methodologies they all work the
information is there in the cell-free
DNA all you have to do is figure out
clever ways of testing port so now we'll
look at testing in the lowest population
because testing in the high-risk
population started being recommended
back in 2012
once ACOG and others found out that the
testing actually is reliable there are
some false negatives there are a few
false positives but very very
you so women who are let's say over age
35 with a risk of about one in 154 downs
on average you could test those 150
pregnancies of the 149 that didn't have
a pregnancy with Down syndrome remember
only two or three per thousand you so in
150 women aged 35 enola you might have
no false positives and there's a 98 99
percent chance that you'll identify that
one down so the vast majority of the 150
women would get a great reduction in
their risk for Down syndrome and when I
say down syndrome you know I don't want
to have to keep tagging on trisomy 18
tries to me 13 but they're perhaps not
quite as good a test but they're still
you know it's really very good
and so if you do look at high-risk women
like over age 35 ultrasound abnormality
family history you that this test is
being used basically to reduce the the
number of women that need invasive
testing so if you know that this woman's
at very low risk because a negative
cell-free DNA test she may choose not to
have amniocentesis and they recommended
that at that time not testing twin
pregnancies there's more data now it
seems to work reasonably well I'll talk
about micro deletion and sex aneuploidy
a little bit later but in the high-risk
population is pretty well set if you had
a test failure it was pretty straight
forward anyway they were already at high
risk you've already talked to them about
an invasive testing so if your cell free
DNA test happened to fail you could say
well we could try again we could get a
serum test or you know what you could
just have invasive testing because
you're already considered to be at high
risk so how does testing in the general
pregnancy population differ from the
high-risk population well the first
thing is the predictive values the test
has the same detection false positive
rate but the prevalence is much lower so
in the high-risk population the the
positive predictive value could easily
be
seven true positives to everyone false
positive or five to one or nine to one
or something in the lowest population
it's it's unlikely to be that high it
might be one to one it might be three to
one five to one but it's going to be
they're going to be more false positive
results and and so it look the test is
still working the same there's just less
to detect in fact if I had a perfect
test 100% detects rate and no false
positives what's the predictive value in
a population that doesn't have the
disease the answer is the predictive
value zero it's useless because there's
no disease so the predictive value is a
combination of detection false positive
and prevalence and I just mentioned this
what about test failures no calls in the
high-risk they're already offered
diagnostic testing not much of an issue
but in the lowest population is the best
thing to do just say oh go have an amnio
maybe not maybe there's some other
options like repeating the cell-free DNA
or having a high-resolution ultrasound
level to ultrasound and what about
counseling and education and the
high-risk those women are likely already
seeing a genetic counseling or a genetic
specialist in the low risk there's
simply too many people in general
population it was the the the initial
counseling and description of the test
and whatever I think would really have
to come from primary care providers and
that was the point of a study that we
did in Rhode Island I'll just show you a
little bit about that the aims of the
study it's a demonstration project
mainly having to do with clinical
utility
we weren't really testing does the test
work we were really testing can we
introduce this test with the primary
obstetric care providers doing the
initial counseling and so we made sure
we had good patient educational
materials we worked with the providers
we did surveys to document that we told
them they were going to improve the
detection rate and reducing false
positives but you know what's the same
when they
a screen positive they did the same
thing with a screen positive for cell
free as they did with a screen positive
for serum screening they referred it now
they they had to say the right the right
sorts of things but actually what they
had to do was pretty much the same as
before they had to maybe you know say
the word cell free DNA now and they had
to learn a little bit more but it's
really not that different for
introduction optional detection of sex
aneuploidies there were no financial
barriers here we offered free testing
for nine months to anybody who who
wanted it even the insurance was not
billed and I'm not gonna address the
last one so there was the booklet and it
was at the 8th grade level same criteria
was met it had all the content that was
recommended at the time by the
professional organizations and the only
thing I'm gonna really focus on here is
uptake and and what what we found so
there are really seven large group
practices in Rhode Island Rhode Island's
very small small state but of the seven
large practices to said I'm not
interested a cog says you shouldn't do
this in the general population which was
true in in 2014 when we did this or they
thought oh gosh DNA this is just this is
too much but five of them said yeah sure
we'll give it a shot and all of them
received in-house training those five
centers ended up enrolling 82 percent of
the women so they were the majority
group as expected and the last one I'm
gonna show you they exceeded the number
of women who had serum screening in the
previous six months this is the
advantage of looking at the large
practices we had a very good fix on how
many pregnancies
they were screening in the previous six
months a weekly rate I think they all of
these practices enrolled more than 50
new pregnancies per month so here we
have the week of enrollment of the study
versus the ratio of testing now what
that means is that this line at a
hundred percent says if I if I have a
dot above that line I'm sorry boy
hello that line it means that the
integrated test that was our main test
is the primary test ene first or the
free DNA test
is now the primer I should say we DNA
first was the idea of you you you're
using DNA as the first test in the first
trimester and so most of these samples
were in the first trimester so here we
have one site I get kind of gave it as a
dashed line they started it week one
they were doing more serum screening
than they were DNA screening in the
previous six months but look by the
sixth week they got over a hundred
percent in other words whatever their
previous six month average was they were
now about ten percent higher than that
and there's where we start counting and
then we look at what they did after that
up to the end of the study and the
average there was thirty percent so they
actually ended up screening once they
got the hang of things thirty percent
more women than they had in the previous
six months that's a that's a big
increase and and you know there's
questions about well where did that
increase come from here's two more early
adopters we call them early adopters
because they started also at week one
this group very quickly by week three
exceeded and ended up with a thirteen
percent higher rate this group you know
had some struggles and it was really not
until week thirteen that they broke the
barrier of 100 percent but then from
then on they averaged 14 percent above
now here are the last two I didn't
they're called laggards people who are
late in adopting I don't I think
laggards is maybe a little pejorative so
I said there the later adopters and you
see they didn't even try until week 15
or so then they heard the other
practices were doing pretty good by week
15 they said we better get going well it
only took this this site one week to get
up to 100% and it just took this one
only about three or four weeks to get up
this was a plus forty percent this was a
plus
so all five large practices ended up
testing an average of more women with
cell-free DNA than they did with serum
screening so not only is cell-free DNA a
better test in higher detection and
lower false positive it also appears as
though more women and more providers
once they're informed are are interested
in in offering and receiving such tests
so what happened well overall twenty six
ninety one women enrolled nineteen of
them never got an initial test result
mainly because FedEx lost one of our
packages that was being sent to the
laboratory we didn't do the testing
in-house it was done in a commercial
laboratory but 13 of those 19 came back
later this is depressing that you know a
woman wanted to have the test and there
was either insufficient volumes damaged
or it got lost and six of them just kind
of gave up that's unfortunate so
thirteen came back so this number of
women got tested we were using the snip
methodology this was a study funded by
Nate era and they at the time could not
do twins they do now and they can't do a
pregnancy where the mother is not
related to the fetus so these really
should never have been tested so we only
reported 2681 test results so what
happened in those test results there
were only sixteen screen positives only
six per thousand women were screened
positive and if we look down here all of
them got genetic counseling there were
nine trisomy 21 positives seven were
true positives to false positives 3:18
all were true positives 4:13 - true
positives - false positives so if you
wanted to look at the predictive value
it's 12 - 4 which is about three to one
and that this isn't a general population
you don't expect the positive predictive
value to be terribly high it's not gonna
be 90 95 98% it was 75 percent as
probably about their uux
but false positive those two plus those
two four out of 2681 or about 0.15
percent so the performance was was kind
of as expected so what did the women do
as I said they all saw a genetic
specialist specialist seventy-five
percent of them 12 chose to have a CBS
or a nanny I think most of them were
amnio's that's where three false
positives nine true positives were
identified seven terminated one was a
inner uterine fetal death and one was a
live born on the other side four of them
did not choose there was one false
positive three true positives that ended
up having you know normal birth exam
three true positives two diagnosed after
birth one i UF d that was karyotype
products of conception so in the general
population which is you know where where
we have to think about going in the
future
high-risk is is pretty well now
established and reimbursed by insurance
companies but what about the general
population and what our laboratories and
and people doing about cell-free DNA
testing well what's happening is they're
looking at additional targets and sex
chromosome aneuploidies turn out to be
one which you know there's the mono so
many externa syndrome which you can
identify with oftentimes a high end t
measurement and then the country common
sex trisomies and obviously if you're
going to do sex chromosome aneuploidy
you're gonna figure out what the fetal
sex is and that's something that you
know a lot of couples want to know early
they're going to find out by ultrasound
or some other method what it is I'm not
terribly concerned about them figuring
it out at least in the United States
early in China you're not allowed to
report anything but a sex chromosome
abnormality you can't report a normal
male or female anyway I don't know if
you know there's argument
about are these serious enough to
identify on the other hand if you don't
identify them prenatally right now
there's no way to identify them at birth
and many of these are identified not
until much later when it's past the time
they might have some treatments that
that would ameliorate some of the
symptoms so you know this is not
unreasonable but it maybe should be an
option now those groups that are doing
shotgun methods they can find other
things as we said earlier like trisomy
16 or trisomy - the problem with this
low resolution scan is you know what
exactly are you supposed to do with the
knowledge that there's a trice because
clearly the fetus is not priced may 16
because that's not compatible with life
by the time you're at 12 14 16 weeks it
must be confined placental mosaicism of
trisomy 16 and yes there might be some
low birth weight preterm delivery and
you might want to watch more but you
know that's questionable but again
that's what people are doing they're
also starting to do micro deletions now
I hate using the phrase large micro
deletions but that's essentially what
they're doing they can only find micro
deletions that are 2 to 3 megabytes or
larger some of them like Cree - I think
is 1012 megabytes I mean it you can you
can see that on a on a karyotype so
they're they're looking for common ones
like DiGeorge syndrome and or large ones
the gorge I think the critical region is
only one and a half or two megabytes
that's about as small as most of them
though unfortunately the detection rate
may not be that high there's a higher
false positive grade a lower predictive
value some of these things like the sex
chromosome aneuploidies Laboratories
really don't need to charge more for but
micro deletions most are adding an
additional charge so the test is
identifying more more disorders but it's
starting to cost more as well and it's
already a relatively expensive test so
what about these things what about if
you have a an ultrasound finding like a
truncal defect and/or family history of
DiGeorge syndrome is this what you
should do
Wow let's look if the DNA tested screen
negative you probably ought to do
targeted testing anyway because
cell-free DNA is not going to identify a
hundred percent of those microdeletion
some of them you know one and a half
mega bases may may be missed so if even
if it's screen negative you ought to be
doing further testing what if it's
screen positive well screen positive
there's already documented cases of
false positives you deletions that are
close to the critical region but don't
include it so you have to do further
testing so why are you doing cell free
DNA testing if regardless of what you
get for an answer is you have to do the
targeted testing and when you have
ultrasound findings there may be micro
deletions that have similar ultrasound
findings that are not even being tested
for and the these low resolution whole
genome scans may have an abnormal
finding and you really don't know what
to do with it you know so it's a trisomy
five and you say well what's the
possibility well there could be unique
parental diesem e4 on chromosome five
and you look up well what's the
literature say about uni parental die
Sammy of chromosome five and the answers
nothing and no idea what it it all right
so let's talk about less costly and
complex methods because I gave you some
of the the differences between screening
in the general population and and the
high-risk population but what I didn't
focus on is in the high-risk population
the cost of your DNA testing is kind of
offset by the cost of invasive testing
which is quite high so it makes sense to
offer it because for every women woman
who does not have an amnio because she
has a negative cell-free DNA test
you saved a thousand dollars on the
amnio karyotype but you spend a thousand
dollars on the DNA so it's a it's a wash
but in the general population
first there's four times as many women
in the general population than the
high-risk population
and there are there are fewer costs to
offset so one thing and I do think that
plays into the recommendations of should
you routinely test in the general
population and why insurance companies
are hesitant to cover general population
cell-free DNA testing well there's two
groups that that are active in that area
right now one is a group in Germany life
codex I have a test called q ni PT I
just this is right out of I know genome
web or something
life codec got a c e mark for its it
it's a this is a pure methylation based
test and it's it says it's going to be
cost efficient and rapid I don't have
that much information about how
cost-efficient and how rapid but I think
they were targeting things for for this
test costing under $100 and being able
to be done in a day unfortunately it's
well singleton pregnancies only isn't
that big of a difference but it's only
good for trisomy 21 it won't identify
anything else or fetal sex but to show
that that low-cost and rapid it it may
be it's licensed by lifecell for use in
India just last year so you know people
are thinking about trying to get
something less expensive the second one
this study just came out in the last
month or so and this is a non next-gen
method I'm not going to go through the
methodology you can look at this
actually if you look at the report you
can see the discussion that has to do
with it but it uses rolling circle
amplification rather than PCR and this
set of colored dots looks a lot like
what you might see from an Illumina
platform but that's not the sequence of
a single base base pair that it each one
of those is the color of a fragment so
the 21 fragments might be red the 18
fragments might be blue and so you just
put this into a scanning microscope and
simply count the number so this is a
targeted counting method that does not
use PCR and does not
next-gen sequence and I have to have to
acknowledge here that we were it very
interested in this and we have a
contract now to do a clinical trial in
Rhode Island with this methodology
because we think it might be a whole lot
less expensive far less tech time far
less reagents far less equipment just
question them does it work as well now
there's a group who are arguing arguing
that cell-free DNA is really robbing
women of a really good option which is
diagnostic testing you know why screen
if you can know the answer and this
these groups make the chromosome will
micro arrays you know are far superior
in identifying deletions and micro
deletions then a karyotype is there are
I think reasonably good arguments that
the procedure related loss of an amnio
receive at CVS is relatively low I took
this right out of one of the their
papers says one in five on or less in
expert hands you do have to know that
it's becoming difficult for
obstetricians and MF M to train for
amnio's because there's so few amnio is
being done now so I agree with this
perhaps one in 500 in less than expert
hands but these experts are starting to
retire CMAs you know find all the and
everything that a cell-free can find
right now a CMA confine including the
off target chromosome so they can do all
the micro deletions not just a subset of
the large one they can go down to two
very small micro deletions micro
duplications large deletions and
duplications and there's pretty good
evidence from an NIH study that you get
serious or profound disorders can be
identified on a CMA for these micro
deletions and whatever in up to 1.5
percent of pregnancies yeah it's it's
really surprisingly common so here's
just some things from the supporters you
can read them you know the again it's a
Mark Evans and Ron Wapner
Berkowitz basically saying micro lead
deletions are really common the women
should be told that there are a lot of
other serious things and they should be
offered the opportunity to have an
invasive test with a chromosomal
microarray and that over the next few
years more and more women will become
educate educated such that the pendulum
may swing back from cell-free to CBS CMA
of course the issue is even if women
understand that is are they going to
choose to have this invasive procedure
yeah that's been the issue all along
even if the risk is one in 500 what's
their decision-making going to end up
with and there are people who argue on
the on the on the other side that
cell-free DNA shouldn't be seen as a
threat and and you know there are
ethanol economic and ethical Quandt
consequences you're you're making the
presumption that you know you need to
test every prank
every normal infant in uncomplicated
pregnancies with the invasive diagnostic
tests it medical eise's pregnancy more
more perhaps than is necessary but for
some some women they admit you know they
they want everything and it's important
and one of the challenges as we can
always say is to make sure that women
are sufficiently informed that they make
the choice that they're most happy with
and and we may be shortchanging a bit
the the information about diagnostic
testing now what about other types of
genetic disorders autosomal recessive
borders well as you know historically
these were race or ethnicity based
Caucasians and Jewish populations were
tested for cystic fibrosis the CFTR gene
it's it's really quite quite common and
african-americans Asians sometimes for
sickle-cell disease but then there was a
question of well what about mixed
ethnicity although cystic fibrosis is
more common in Caucasian Jewish it still
occurs in other populations you know and
now that we were able to to do more
cost-effective screening of more
considering pan-ethnic screening and
weather testing should be done pre
conceptually or prenatally the disorder
should be serious enough to consider
termination currently many of these
programs that are testing for 50 100 150
recessive disorders are moving moving
from the targeted mutations to just
sequencing the gene so instead of
looking at for example in CFTR you know
102 the 23 from ACMG or a hundred and
whatever that are known to be Dilla
tereus they'll just sequence it and use
their next-gen sequencing and calling
algorithms to determine whether it's
pathogenic or not but there are you know
generally patients can choose what's on
the panel the panels there they could
have a small panel or a big panel but
they can't say well I'm really
interested in disease ABC and when you
get to 150 diseases I'm not sure
patients would be capable of deciding
which ones they want or not but if you
if you keep it with sufficiently serious
to consider termination I think that may
be the way to go another thing that's
interesting is is in doing this testing
in the population it's surprising how
often they identify the mother or father
as being homozygous or compound
heterozygous for one of these four CFTR
they might have a you know a real doula
tereus mutation and then I'm moderately
a moderate mutation and now you're into
counseling the the parents about things
and also screening for diseases that are
less severe you really want to I think
trying to avoid that prenatally but how
does this maybe come in to CF I thought
I'd just give one example here the dhcr
seven gene is associated with using
smith Laemmle obits syndrome and I'll
just point so here you go I'm sorry
tell you what this is this is kind of a
box of all that one of the panels can
identify and you see cystic fibrosis is
39% of all the affected and no it's 32
per hundred thousand or seventeen
percent of all the profound serious
disorders this is the hemoglobinopathies
the green are special cases you can't
really do with next-gen sequencing
fragile X and so on but I'm picking
Smith phlegm leo pits just as an example
it's a pretty big box and you say wow I
didn't realize sniffle Emily opens was
was that common well its autosomal
recessive some mildly affected
individuals most severe cases the
carrier frequency in Caucasians about
one in sixty which says there should be
about one in fourteen thousand couples
that have a concepts us with SLE OS but
the birth prevalence is one in twenty to
one sixty thousand and we did a study in
the second trimester where we could
identify most SLS cases through the
serum screening program and we came up
with even accounting for the ones we
couldn't find it's probably only about
one in a hundred thousand births well
why the discrepancies there's more and
more Sheen coming out that obviously the
carrier rate gives you the concept of
this but there's very high early fetal
loss so the carrier frequency is not
predictive of SLE OS even in the
probably the first or second trimester
must much less at birth so if we go back
to this this box is actually way too
large this box is really way too large
because it includes trait carriers as
well as those that are severely affected
so you have to be a little bit careful
with some of them the numbers that get
thrown around for the number of affected
individuals are affected fetuses
identified but still that most of them
are are correct now autosomal dominant
is interesting it's it's something that
actually can be done both with expanded
carrier screening and with cell free DNA
they're about ten to fifteen disorders
that are in
included on cell-free DNA panels here
and there including you know I've listed
four of them here unfortunately there
isn't a lot of information about how
well they're identified elevated NT is
we you know we talked a little bit of
for is a marker for Noonan syndrome but
should you use this test for Noonan
syndrome or should you use a more
sensitive test so there's questions
about the predictive value and and
interestingly the cost of this test
probably is more than an expanded
carrier screen which will test for a
whole lot more disorders right now so
although it's possible to identify some
it I'm not sure it's competitive right
now but but it is being offered now
there's also this a few groups that have
played around with high resolution whole
genome whole X X Jo exome of the fetus
based on cell free DNA now I'll do the
classic I know you can't read this
because if you even if you could read it
I'm not sure I could explain it to you
but this was a study back in 2012
Steven quake and his group from
California but the thing I want you to
really focus on is current cell-free DNA
sequence about as few as two and some
groups sequence perhaps as many as 20
million fragments this is nine hundred
and thirty million fragments this is not
something that's going to be
cost-competitive in the near future but
it didn't work and and they they showed
that it did this is a one that it was
actually earlier in 2010 and I just show
you this because they actually did it
did 3.9 billion a line reads about a 65
fold coverage and I think they were
trying to identify yeah the fetus the
parents were carriers and the fetus was
heterozygous for beta thalassemia so
they actually could make a kind of a
fetal diagnosis based on these this
whole genome so the three colors are the
the fetus the mother and the father I'm
not sure which ones which
and this same group group from Chinese
University of Hong Kong now has an
updated method that just came out in
2016 and and they went from 65 fold
which I just showed you was nine point
three billion reads to two hundred and
thirty fold coverage which is what about
four times more so instead of nine
billion it's now 36 billion aligned
reads are needed in the second
generation but they actually showed that
they could identify a mutation
to 85% of mutations that would be
identified using a whole genome scan on
pure fetal material so they're getting
pretty close to identifying most and the
positive predictive value is up in the
60 70 percent so when they found one
there was a you know 60 or 70 percent
chance that it was true which which is
okay but you can see that this is not
something that's going to be in in
general use in the near future
now what about fetal cells in the
maternal circulation you've heard about
this before as well well but what would
be the advantage of this I should say
advantage is really well one of the
disadvantages of fragmented cell-free
DNA is it's not a whole the whole genome
but it's not intact well a whole fetal
cell would would have a completely
intact fetal genome it would be much
easier to identify copy number variants
and things like for recessive diseases
you don't need to screen the father you
can imagine something like I collect
plasma I test the cell-free DNA for
carrier status of the mother or the
buffy coat for the carrier status of the
mother and for anything that she's a
carrier for I'll do a I'll test this the
fetal cells to see what the fetus is
there's no need to worry about testing
the father and the questions of
non-paternity with the father
you only need to test really the mother
or the fetus or really the fetus alone
but the mother and the fetus might save
you some time and effort well there's
some what's water what are some of the
issues there
there's stories about you know
circulating male cells from a previous
pregnancy when the current pregnancy is
female early in pregnancies that may be
difficult to capture any or only a very
few fetal cells and this is a lot of
work it could it could be that it's
going to be quite costly I don't know
anyone that's actually offering this
right now as a routine test well if the
first group had studied this back in
2002 was the Nifty study they often
couldn't get fetal cells low detection
high false positive rate the likelihood
is that some of the cells they were
collecting were not actually fetal cells
and from 2002 for about 10 years very
little I mean almost 15 years now 10 to
12 years very little was done with fetal
cell but recently there's been a lot of
work with it just because it's been so
many advances in in molecular diagnostic
molecular techniques I've just chosen
two of the more recent ones this group
identified between 14 and 22 new
fellated red blood cells in I don't know
it's like 15 pregnancies and they also
looked at site a trophoblasts where they
got one to forty four using 4 ml of
maternal blood which is kind of what is
used for cell free DNA they did it at 11
to 13 weeks which is kind of the target
area you like they performed fish an
array CGH after whole genome
amplification and they had a 21 and 18
and 13 in their group of 10 to 15 and
they correctly identified all of the
cases and this is clearly proof of
concept this other group of fetal
nucleated red blood cells they were at
18 weeks they had a few more affected
samples 21 18 13s and to sex chromosome
and employees and got all of those
correct but again this is labor
intensive expensive and but it may be on
the horizon as another option so in
summary then current cell free DNA
for the common autosomal trisomies or
some of the other aneuploidies high
sensitivity and specificity
it's tending toward including more
targets at higher cost this is the same
thing that's happened to computers
remember you know you could have from 20
years ago the cost of that computer is
probably two dollars but no one wants
what that computer can do anymore they
want a computer that does more and it's
the same trend here it turned out to be
the same thing with cystic fibrosis
screening could we get the cost of
testing 23 mutations down low the answer
was it was not easy to do because
companies wanted to compete on numbers
of mutation rather than cost on the same
thing seems to be happening with
cell-free DNA the competition is what
can I find rather than what the cost is
but in the third bowl of that says well
doing that kind of competition it may be
difficult to transition cell free to the
general pregnancy population that's what
we're going through right now the tests
are really good they're finding more
things but they're getting more
expensive rather than than cheaper when
you find all those things they can
identify some dominant they can't really
do recessive very well right now
prenatal diagnosis with with the
microwave show Dizz is far better its
diagnostic and it and it finds more if
certainly of the duplication so RB
deletion digital but they find the
duplication and deletion disorders
cell-free really is only focused on the
deletions larger deletions right now in
depth whole genome using cell free DNA
is possible but it's very expensive and
same thing with cell free or excuse me
cell based testing again it's promising
there's some interesting things that you
can do with it but it needs further
development questions about cost so I
think that that does it I thank you for
for listening and and and hope it's been
helpful thank you dr. Glen Palomar
for me in presentation we will now start
the lack of an impression in the webinar
if you have a question they'd like to
please just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as enough time
for let's get started
our first question is and then all
pregnant women have genetic counseling
prior to mr. Fibrosis DNA screening cell
based screening
yeah that's aspirational goal that would
be nice
but we did a quick analysis and and
found that if you were going to give a
about a twenty minute
genetic counselor based session for the
the general pregnancy population that
might be tested which is maybe two two
and a half million pregnancies that
would take all the genetic counselors
that are likely to graduate in the next
ten years and clearly they have other
things they need to do as well so that
might be you know an aspirational goal
but it's just not reasonable and and
that was part of the reason we did our
DNA first study to show that with proper
training primary care providers can do
this they feel comfortable in doing it
we believe they do a good job again we
we tested the women women's knowledge
and decision-making and and they did as
well as as can be expected nothing's
perfect but they did reason with most
people most women understood what was
going on with cell-free DNA screening in
after talking with their primary care
provider but thanks thanks for a
question thank you for that answer
my next question is why is the cause of
testing not coming down
I thought NGS was going to allow for a
hundred-dollar gene yes yeah I noticed
I've been to a few talks about next-gen
sequencing and I haven't seen that chart
from NIH for a while you remember the
chart that started off the Oh doing a
genome with them
you know $3,000,000 then it was a
million dollars then it was five hundred
thousand and King came down in a
logarithmic fashion cut being you know
cut in half or whatever every year until
about 2010 2011 and I don't think it's
changed that much since 2010 2011 so the
idea of being able to do the sequencing
for you know all the sequencing you need
for a hundred dollars you know has not
arrived and again what what most many
clinical laboratories are doing is is
adding so if you want to do micro
deletions you actually have to do deeper
sequencing so even if the cost came down
per base pair you're doing more base
pairs so the cost is going to go up
because of that but maybe down because
of the sequencing costs so I think there
has to be a you know a different way of
doing it and I showed you you know two
methods that that don't follow the
standard path of of a next-gen
sequencing that's out there the
methylation based and the non PCR based
good question thank you our next
question is the risk of invasive testing
is lower than thought why screen when
diagnostic testing costs about the same
well that's true in the high-risk
population that cell-free DNA testing
kind of is roughly the same prices as an
invasive diagnostic test maybe a little
bit lower now but in the general
population you're most women are not
going to have a diagnostic test you saw
that there are some groups that argue
let's make sure that the women are
informed about the advantages of
invasive testing or diagnostic testing
but still in the general population
they're likely to be very few amnio's
avoided whereas every woman is going to
get a cell-free DNA test so there's
there's not the balance in the general
population that you see in the high-risk
population and again that may be why
insurance companies are you know and and
professional societies are holding back
a little bit in
commending testing in the general
pregnancy population thanks I would like
to once again thank dr. Glenn Paula Maki
for his presentation I would also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know the
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through July of 2018
you will receive an email from labrys
letting you know in this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement music colleague some admin
students live Matt that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
goodbye